you guys need to respect the century
check this out so because the Century's
heavily inspired by Superman the two
characters have very similar power sets
the century has super strength speed
durability and of course he can fly he
can make himself invisible and phase
through solid objects he has telekinesis
telepathy size and shape alteration and
could heal himself and others and even
resurrect the dead he can manipulate
matter at a molecular level and his
skill at matter manipulation is so
prodigious he was able to manipulate the
molecules within the molecule man Owen
Reese one of the most powerful beings in
existence he was able to fight World
breaker Hulk to a standstill he battled
Galactus to his stalemate his advanced
healing abilities allow him to recover
from being completely destroyed and more
recently an Annihilation Scourge baby
Ray Bill number one the century was able
to rip a hole in reality make sure you
guys follow for more